[Music]
let's go to spinx in brewton alabama
spanx what's up dude
how are you dr john rock and rolling man
how about yourself
i'm well thank you
you bet so what's up man
okay so let me give you a brief summary
of kind of how we got here and then i'll
ask my question if that's okay you got
it
so i am a broadcast meteorologist and
you sound like a meteorologist
you sound like one thanks
thank you
so i wanted to do weather and be a
meteorologist pretty much my whole life
i was really fascinated with whether as
a kid and really fortunate to have a
grandmother who
you know created experiences and bought
me things and encouraged me from a very
young age to kind of go down that path
if i chose to sure so graduated college
went to college at the
university of alabama in tuscaloosa you
had to get that in there didn't you you
just had to get that in there
all right i'll give you that one
i actually grew up an auburn fan if that
makes you feel considered
no both of them are they're both
terrible but whatever you got it in
there so there you go
yeah at least you're not an egg all
right go for it
there you go
so went to college and then worked
briefly in television in the birmingham
alabama television market
and then i actually moved back to my
hometown to be a full-time youth
minister which kind of opened my eyes to
a totally different world that i had
never really you know
been in
so i realized about a year into that job
that i wanted to get back into broadcast
weather so i started a company to keep
my feet wet and
that ended up turning into a part-time
job and subsequently a full-time job and
thankfully the company has done really
well and that's due in part to
you know the principle that you all
teach you and dave ramsey on a daily
basis those are kind of ingrained as a
company and really thankful to have kind
of been a ramsey person my whole life
but over the last few years
i've really had more and more people
message me about having severe weather
anxiety
and specifically tornado anxiety
not only you know the messages
but also sometimes when i'm in public
people will see me and want to talk
about their severe weather experiences
and their you know severe weather
anxiety so my question for you is this
what are some effective ways
that i can help to alleviate this severe
weather anxiety and i guess kind of
elaborating on that
what would you say to me
and to people in my industry as a mental
health professional as far as you know
do you have any suggestions on how we
can be more effective communicators
during you know crises like tornadoes
yes dude i love this question
i love it for a few reasons one um
i grew up in houston the gulf and so
i've
i've been sheltering in place and
getting in bathtubs with mattresses
since i was a little bit of a kid right
so i've got
my own
ingrained uh weather anxiety and i i've
had to work through it over the past
five to six or seven years and it's been
i love this question from for a personal
reason
can i be super blunt and honest with you
or you need to like talk peripherally
no be super blunt
okay i'm gonna speak to you as i'm
clowning on you but um it's actually for
the entire ecosystem is that cool yes
absolutely i think i know where this is
going you're such a great person i
appreciate you taking one for the team
right okay
so i think let's answer this from kind
of the top of the funnel anxiety
to make it really easy um it can distill
down into three buckets right
um
am i scared does your body detecting
that something scary is happening
whether you're an abusive relationship
you're not safe
it remembers a time when you drove on
this road and you were making this left
turn when you got in a bad car accident
so it's gonna start it put a pin in that
right so there's safety then there is
disconnection like i don't i'm out of
step with my community i don't have any
relationships my body has found me alone
it's gonna sound the alarms or the third
one is autonomy right i am not in
control of tomorrow i'm not in control
of my next step
and when we get in weather situations
that's one of those few moments
when you are completely and totally out
of control
you're scared to death and often we find
ourselves isolating alone so feeling
anxious about weather
is right and it's good and it's not
something that we're not broken when we
when we get nervous about it what
happens though is the ecosystem that
we've created for ourselves when it
comes to how media communicates weather
i think has shifted from i'm giving you
good information to i need to get clicks
and sell ads
and this
this is literally it's a it's a this is
a critique of the
internet media of course but it's bled
over into
public right
so now i when it's raining outside
um
i can turn on the news just to check it
out and it will be
a big bright bold red
breaking news breaking weather update
right you see what i'm saying everything
is designed to get me to focus in on
there and to sound the alarms that i'm
not safe right
sure and
there's the broader conversation that
tells us that because of climate change
we're going to have more tornadoes more
hurricanes are going to be more
aggressive we're going to have hail
storms the crops are going to all fail
right what's the latest one is
that the government is and rich people
are drumming up a food shortage like
we're being fed this all the time that
we're going to die we're going to die
we're going to die and that weather and
climate are the reason
and so that that's coming from the
inside out right
and
storms are escalating and the weather's
bananas and what used to be right right
so it is actually happening too and so
it's this both and um so i think it's
your question is incredibly important
because you sit at as the person people
go to when they're anxious or when
they're scared and they've got all this
baggage that they're bringing with them
and they look at you and say
help right and so then what do we do
and i think from my perspective too
i'm kind of in a unique position because
like i said i started a company
essentially
being you know the tv weather caster but
i own you know the company from from the
top down right and so i think too a lot
of folks don't realize or it seems to me
that a lot of folks don't realize that
these larger media conglomerates that
own
these local television stations you're
right are pushing the narrative you know
from the top down and sometimes that
you know can lead to um
you know local meteorologists pushing
things in a way that may not be as
helpful not to say that they're not
doing good work i think they are of
course
but i think that a lot of folks don't
realize that you know a lot of this is
um you know being pushed from the top
sometimes right and
that when they tell you hey things just
turned you're good
that message isn't always communicated
because the goal is to keep you on right
because i want you to keep watching the
watching the station so
here whenever i'm sitting down with
somebody who's struggling with anxiety
of any kind
a couple of things guide my path there
okay number one is presence i'm gonna
show up
and i think a a
someone who's doing weather is uniquely
positioned especially someone who's not
market hopping and you know how that
whole riga maru goes i'm gonna do two
years on this one and one we're here and
all that
somebody who creates a stable presence
i'll be here right
and you can trust me and you can also
trust that i'm gonna probably oversell
it this way or undersell it this way we
had a guy in one of my communities i
lived in they'd call him run for the
hill
ron roberts or whatever his name was but
but but but also everybody went to him
every single time
and right like it's kind of like delony
comes in and i'm like i saw the best
movie ever they know it wasn't the best
movie ever but they know it's pretty
good but they know me right there's a
presence
and so presence is number one a big one
that i follow is facts are your friends
when somebody's stressed out when
somebody is fried what they need is
very limited true data
when a mother
opens the door and there's an officer
standing there in full uniform and i'm
standing there
she instantly knows something's happened
if i start with well it was raining
really hard and there were cars right
that's not how you do that
you open the door and say ma'am there
was a car accident and your son was in
the car and he has died
facts are your friends and there's a
period there and i'm going to be i'm
going to say it directly i'm going to
say it forward right and then
after we pick her up and take her inside
over the next couple of hours there will
be discussions and back and forth and
one of the things that i was trying to
do that i'm pretty good at is
those conversations go up and down and
up and down and up and down so there's
going to be some strange moments of deep
guttural laughter sometimes and there's
going to be some deep moments of fear
and scared and what do we do and here's
a here's who you call next
so i use that example to tell you
the best group i've ever seen and i grew
up in texas you know how volatile the
weather is in texas
the the the best i've ever seen is this
crew here in nashville the the nashville
severe weather it's a couple of guys who
have a twitter account and i don't even
have twitter but i follow them and
here's why it's great
they say things like hey it's past go to
bed
get off the computer they'll skip an all
clear in other words yeah it's an all
clear but it's an all clear like i would
get from a buddy
not an all clear from an ai
um
they give funny memes
in between their reports and also
they're very um direct when they say
go get under something now
if you're in this area
and they use that very sparingly and so
what i've come in my four years i've
been in nashville five years i've been
in tennessee
i've come to trust they're funny they're
gonna have moments of levity
if they say jump you better jump because
they're not messing around they're not
playing with you
and they tell me go to bed their goal
isn't to keep me on there as long as
possible their goal is to give me
accurate information
does that make sense
it does make sense yeah so those three
things i think in someone in your like
as a public figure is i'm gonna show up
every time i'm gonna i'm gonna be a
presence for you and i'm gonna give you
true data true information and if it's
no big deal i'm gonna say this is no big
deal go back to bed if it's a huge deal
i'm gonna tell you and three i'm gonna
intersperse humor and connection
wherever i can right whether that's
funny memes whether that's the dad joke
of the day or whether that's whatever
that is here's a recipe for staying up
late since you're going to be up late
tonight because they're going to be
tornadoes all over your area those kind
of things does that make sense
it does make sense absolutely
um i think some leadership in the area
of here's what i'm here's what i'm i'm
nervous about i don't say i'm actually
scared about it
i'm scared that with escalating weather
and this isn't a political statement and
i still can't belie i can't figure out
for the life of me how weather has
gotten politicized it's bananas to me
right but as it has
become increasingly more volatile and
increasingly more wild right and the
temperature swings in the ring all that
the more noise there is
the more people just disregard it
and the more dangerous it becomes for
everybody and so i would love to see
someone like you sphinx who
says i'm going to be a part of this new
generation
of meteorologists and we're going to
start a conversation that says hey how
do we connect with our communities again
and not try to get them to buy metamucil
ads
whatever the thing that's going to come
up how can we give them some information
that's going to help them sleep and help
them stay safe
instead of
let's get them wound up right and i know
i know that's so easier said than done
because of the conglomerates you're
talking about but
well and this may be a topic for another
day but what would you say like one of
the things that i encounter pretty
frequently
you know we see on social media um
people who have no training in
meteorology you know even sometimes
teenagers that get on facebook and you
know post these wild um single image
model runs and kind of pass them off as
a forecast but then they go viral
because um you know it's the shock
factor right and well what do you say
like
to folks who kind of are in tune to that
sort of thing
but but you know perhaps should be more
in tune like a local person who is
trained
um two things one you're exactly right
our brains are designed to scan the
environment for the worst possible
outcome because that's how it stays
alive
and
5 000 years ago if or 50 million years
ago whatever if a twig snapped in the
forest it's better that i assume that's
a bear even though it's probably not
because if i'm wrong i'm dead and if i'm
right i just jumped really high nothing
happened right
now you take that same brain wiring and
fast forward and now some 17 year old
with with a with a computer model and a
twitter account can
keep an entire neighborhood awake right
and screw up their weather patterns and
their traffic patterns and their
shopping all that stuff
so um i think that we have to have a
generation that pops up real fast
yourself included i'm thinking of the
elaine norton's of the word world the
sal the stefano and the mind pump guys
with fitness um i'm thinking of huberman
when it comes to some of the mental
health stuff and science
this show your show
that will call that out directly
do not get weather advice from a
knuckleheaded facebook account
right i'm just going to call it what it
is and say somebody is
running their mouth they don't know what
they're talking about um here is actual
data here's actual science and if you
build that trust over time
uh
and you don't become an alarm sounder
all the time unless you really need to
sell the alarm then people begin to
trust you but there's going to take a
group of people who actually know what
they're talking about to come out of our
laboratories and come off out of our
um
our circles i just like to hang out with
mental health folks that's what i love
to do and i like to hang out with
doctors and lawyers
i've got to leave those circles and
start communicating some of this truth
in other ways right so i think i think
you've got to call that out directly and
if somebody if if a group of people
tweet you five or six or seven of the
same photo call it out
say hey i keep getting this photo this
is nonsense hey uh frank at
frank's garage 87
like stop posting stuff you're going to
get people hurt this is nonsense and
it's great
right and i think calling it out
gotcha that's a great one good to know i
think i think it's clear to say that
maybe a little um it's certainly easier
said than done especially when you know
the oh everything i just oh dude
everything i just said is easier said
than done yes no question oh sure
totally not saying it's not worth it i
think it is but uh
definitely easier said than done yeah i
no i i think there's got to be some sort
of collective movement to center things
back
um not politically again i don't want to
get your mean cards and letters
everybody but center it back
things are getting crazy when it comes
to weather things are getting extreme
and things are speeding up and
i need to know when it's a big deal for
me or not i need to know when there's a
pattern that's happening over right so i
need to know some of this true data but
i also need it in a not sensationalized
time because it's just a big game of boy
cried wolf
and now people are just starting to
check out right they're just saying i'm
completely out of this conversation
so whether you're a parent whether
you're a
therapist whether you're a psychologist
whether you're a medical doctor whether
you are a meteorologist like sphinx in
his communities whatever you do
the more you bang on drums and cry wolf
the education system's falling apart
we're all gonna it's not it's not
is it a mess right now absolutely
absolutely
um i just was in a meeting this morning
i just i'm i'm taking this on the left
turn but i'm but i'll come back i was
just in a meeting this morning my comp
the company that i worked for um there's
about 1100 employees adopted a single
school this year
and they gave every employee a week off
to go
support this school
there's a group of us a big group of us
that are going to get certified as
substitute teachers
who are going to get certified as aids
who are going to
groups have already come in and cut out
things for teachers make copies do
coffee make breakfasts
take this school over and support and
love them
because education is not broken teachers
teaching kids isn't broken
it's teachers having to be
roofers and pavement
employees they have to and craftsmen
and social workers and therapists and
deal with their own homes all for barely
minimum wage and if you do the hour
sometimes it's not even minimum wage so
it's time for people like companies in
like local communities and local
churches to step up and start taking
care of some of these schools right so
that's a group of people in a community
stepping up and saying we have a problem
here let's be a part of the solution
let's just don't throw grenades on
facebook same with same with the weather
same with any number of challenges we
have in our communities let's get a
group of people to step up and start
being a part of that and sphinx shout
out to you and your company for leading
that charge if you are anxious about
whether
finding a
organization find a voice that you trust
whether it's on the internet like the
one i found whether it's a particular um
[Music]
anchor if you will i keep thinking of
anchorman ron burgundy
find somebody who will give you good
information and then
turn it off